hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be breaking down a crazy boku no hero
fan theory that was just given new life
in chapter 330 of the manga what if
shigaraki was actually born quirkless
and his quirk decay was secretly given
to him by all for one without his
knowledge or consent in order to turn
him into exactly the kind of person that
all for one wanted him to become on top
of that what if shigaraki squared decay
originally belonged to deku but was then
stolen from daku by dr ujiko when he was
still a baby and then later given to
shigaraki we are going to be diving into
some extremely interesting mha theory
territory in this video so definitely
stay tuned until the end because as you
will see the twists just keep coming if
you guys enjoy these types of videos and
you want to see more boku no hero
content here on the channel you know
what to do just leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
helps a lot and of course if you're new
to anime outpour or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications finally
this video will of course contain boku
no hero manga spoilers i am using all of
the available information up to this
point so please proceed with caution you
have been warned chapter 330 of the mha
manga is called me and myself and among
other things it deals with the fact that
shigaraki is no longer himself although
he is still in the same body he is not
the tomura shigaraki that we met at the
beginning of the story because part of
all for one's consciousness was
transferred into shigaraki along with
the all for one quirk shigaraki's body
is currently being inhabited by both his
own consciousness and the consciousness
of all for one now all for one's
ultimate goal is to take over
shigaraki's body completely and just
turn him into a new overpowered vessel
for himself
but that plan hasn't worked out the way
all for one was expecting shigaraki has
proven himself to be more stubborn and
resilient than expected and so the
consciousness that currently dwells
within the body of shigaraki is neither
all shigaraki nor all all for one it
seems to be some strange combination of
the two a combination which may
eventually become a completely new and
unique entity at the very end of chapter
330 there is a reference to shigaraki's
childhood home and we see the text it
began in that house with a grain of hate
that grew and built upon itself while i
was watching a video on this chapter by
a fellow anime youtuber by the name of
zonan i saw that he mentioned the theory
that maybe we are about to learn that
shigaraki was actually born quirkless
and decay only appeared when it did
because all for one secretly transferred
it to a young tenko shimura without his
knowledge or consent
that was all a part of all for one's
master plan to create and mold the
perfect hate-filled being a being that
would one day become all for one's ideal
vessel i will bring zonan in later on in
the video to get his expert opinion on
all of this and definitely check out his
anime channel i will link it in the
description and in the pinned comment
but first let's break down the theory
normally quirks are supposed to show up
before the user reaches the age of 4 and
if someone doesn't develop a quirk by
that age they are usually assumed to be
quirkless and yet little tenkoshimura
was still quirkless at the age of 5
until decay suddenly appeared and tenko
ended up murdering his entire family as
a result most of them he murdered
accidentally because he didn't know how
to control his new quirk but with his
father things were not quite as
accidental according to this tenko was
born quirkless theory the appearance of
decay at that precise moment was not a
coincidence at some point all for one
managed to track down nan ashimura's
family and he had been gathering intel
on them for some time he did this in
part because he hated nana and he wanted
to torment her living relatives but also
in part because he hoped to get intel
about other heroes who were once close
to nana and her family like gran torino
and all might so while secretly
gathering intel on the surviving
shimuras all for one came to understand
the nature of their family dynamic and
he solved the issues that young tenko
was having with his father he also
recognized in tenko a perfect future
vessel for himself a vessel that he
could mold from a very young age to
become exactly who all for one wanted
him to be and why was tenko the perfect
vessel not only was he the grandson of
all for one's former nemesis nana which
would be poetic justice from all for
one's perspective but having been born
quirkless tenko also had the capacity to
take on more quirks later on in life
maybe even one for all itself those who
already have a quirk of their own when
they inherit one for all end up having a
much shorter life span because their
bodies cannot handle one for all and
they burn out but quirkless people like
all might and deku are far better suited
for one for all than people who were
born with a quirk their bodies are able
to handle one for all much much better
than people who already had a quirk
before getting one for all this means
that if tenko really was born quirkless
he would be better suited to one day's
steal one for all so all for one decided
to give young tenko the correct decay at
a strategically opportune time which led
to a confused tenko killing his whole
family and becoming traumatized for life
this began his process of transforming
into the villain known as tomura
shigaraki and the entire thing was
orchestrated by all for one from the
very beginning all all for one had to do
after that was take tenko in and mold
him to become his perfect vessel he also
nurtured shigaraki's immense hatred
because as we now know that very hatred
gives him incredible willpower and
incredible willpower is required to one
day steal one for all since all for one
always intended to take over shigaraki's
body and make him a vessel and since all
for one is a master planner who claims
to have plans that span for multiple
lifetimes in the future it isn't a huge
stretch to assume that he could have
orchestrated shigaraki's childhood
trauma and subsequent breakdown in order
to serve his own sick and twisted
purpose i can definitely get behind this
theory and i would be pretty hyped if it
turned out to be true but now let's talk
about the deku angle the idea that not
only was shigaraki's quirk secretly
given to him by all for one but that
this quirk was actually deku's original
quirk deku's childhood doctor the one
who told dekku that he was quirkless was
none other than dr ujiko the villain
doctor who has been working directly
with all for one for decades this means
that even back when deku was still just
a kid ujiko had already been a villain
for many years and a lot of people
believed that he was only posing as a
children's doctor so that he could
identify children with strong quirks he
would then arrange for all for one to
secretly steal those powerful quirks
from the children later on the doctor
would just tell the children that they
were born quirkless and so no one would
ask any questions and all for one would
get away with it since quirks are
supposed to be hereditary many fans
always thought it was kind of strange
that deku would be born quirkless even
though both of his parents had quirks
and not to mention the concept of quirk
singularity which stipulates that as
time goes on and more people will be
born with more powerful quirks meaning
that quirkless people should already be
becoming less common so that combined
with the fact that deku's childhood
doctor just happened to be the villain
doctor who works with all for one the
guy who literally steals quirks
convinced a lot of people that all of
this was not just some big crazy
coincidence deku ended up with ujico as
his doctor because all for one used
duchiko to steal deku's original quirk
as i said some believe that deku's
original quirk was actually decay and
once all for one stole deku's quirk he
gave it to shigaraki or maybe he
combined deku's quirk with another quirk
to create what we know today as decay
and then gave it to shigaraki that would
be a really interesting and poetic twist
just imagine it the main villain of the
story has killed hundreds of people
using a quirk that actually belonged to
the main hero such a twist would make
the inevitable final showdown between
deku and chigaraki even more powerful
and i'm sure that fans would lose it if
this turned out to be true however there
are two issues with the idea that
shigaraki's quirk might have come from
deku the first is the fact that deku
appears to have two joints on his pinky
toe according to ujico people who have
quirks are further evolved physically
from people without quirks and one clear
sign of that is that quirkless people
have two joints on their pinky toe while
people with quirks have only one if we
accept this to be true then we have to
accept that deku was indeed born
quirkless because he has two joints in
his pinky toe but if ujiko was
deliberately misleading deku and his
mother with that toe information in
order to cover up the fact that he
steals quirks for all for one then it
could still be possible that deku wasn't
born quirkless it all depends on whether
we take fujiko's statements about the
double jointed pinky toe as fact or as
misdirection the other potential issue
is the age gap between shigaraki and
deku shigaraki is roughly five years
older than deku and shigaraki's quirk
suddenly manifested when he was five
years old so for shigaraki to receive
deku's quirk at the age of five deku
would have to have been literally a baby
at the time that his quirk was stolen he
would have had to have been less than a
year old we know that some newborn
babies do in fact manifest their quirks
right away for example the first known
quirk user in the mha world was a
newborn baby that emitted light from its
body this baby is often referred to as
luminescent baby so the only way for
deku to be the original owner of the k
is if the quirk activated while deku was
still a baby maybe even at the hospital
shortly after he was born ujico must
have been at this hospital at that time
he liked the quirk and he decided to
steal it without deku's parents or
anyone else finding out he later tried
to cover all of this up by telling dekku
that he was born quirkless this isn't
technically impossible although it does
require a lot of different pieces to
fall into place at the exact same time
and of course it's possible that even if
shigaraki was really born quirkless and
the k was secretly given to him by all
for one the quirk didn't come from deku
who was an infant at the time it was
just some other quirk that all for one
found either way though it is always so
much fun to speculate about these things
these are some extremely interesting
theories in my opinion and if you enjoy
this type of content and you want to see
more of it in the future don't forget to
leave a like on this video and of course
subscribe to the channel
now i'm going to bring in zonan to get
his take on these fascinating theories
okay joining me now we have fellow anime
youtuber zonin who is i feel an expert
on mha he does a lot of breakdowns of
the spoilers and the chapters and
everything like that and it was while
listening to his video that i kind of
sparked the idea for making this video
so zone and welcome hey thank you for
having me but i think calling me an
expert is maybe a little too generous
but you know we'll see if this stuff
actually turns out to be true then maybe
at that point i could be considered one
but until then uh i'm just a fellow
anime youtuber just trying to make some
awesome content okay listen we have to
clickbait the expert thing okay so you
know go with it and also you know we
could find out as early as but a week
from the time this video
goes live whether it was true or not but
yeah so give me your thoughts
on this theory that shigaraki may have
actually been born quirkless and that
all for one kind of gave him the quirk
decay at just the right strategic moment
in order to create the villain that he
wanted to create
and that it was you know without
shigaraki even realizing it
okay so like i said depending on how
this turns out this could be a very
intricate web that uh horikoshi has
weaved here
not only with just sugar rocky and all
for one but uh izuku also ties into this
possibly possibly yeah so the whole
thing about shigaraki uh ortenko i
should say him getting his quirk when he
was at the age of five
is very peculiar because it's stated
actually very early on in this year that
quirks manifest by the age of four like
it specifically stated that yeah and
another specific thing uh is in a
chapter uh
what did i say it was 235 i think
something uh around there where it's
revealed when uh dk blooms in shigaraki
it shows you the panel of his age like
to put it in your face that hey
he's five yes remember back you know
before i said four was the age where
they're going to manifest and if it
doesn't happen by then then you're out
of luck exactly no that right there is
like the big red flag but also in that
chapter just a couple panels right
before the whole age reveal thing we see
little tenko being dropped off at his
house
by a man who just i mean literally looks
like all for one i mean come on he's
like i mean even if you're like not even
really paying attention if you just look
to this like the size of the guy he's
like as big as the door frame and you
know all for one is notable for being
like an absolute unit you know the way
that all might is and he's dressed like
him he has the hat clearly it is all for
one who has dropped off tenko here
so it is not a coincidence that
you know maybe a couple hours later
after this dk suddenly blooms within him
oh that's really interesting because i
guess i when i read that chapter i just
assumed that was his dad wearing a hat
and kind of like didn't even give it a
second thought exactly and that's what
uh i believe horaco she probably wanted
yeah that's really interesting
yeah because it makes sense like you
said i mentioned earlier in the video
the whole thing about age five and while
we're led to believe that there are such
things as late bloomers because that's
what deku claims to be
because he gets his quirk much later
because he inherits one for all much
later
in fact we don't really know any other
late bloomers i don't think canonically
other than shigaraki or tenko um shimura
if he is a late bloomer at all and we
know that deku was just lying about that
right yeah deku i would say is maybe the
only documented case in their world of
that uh happening but um other than that
to us the audience it is uh tanko but
like i said it's probably bs that's uh
he's not an outlier here but
uh you bringing up uh izuku uh should
probably lead us to the uh other part of
this little rabbit hole because he is
included in this yes exactly so that was
the part about what if deku was born
with a quirk that quirk was actually
decay but it was stolen from him and
given to shigaraki later on right yeah
so that's a very good possibility uh
because the whole aegis thing going back
to that their ages coincidentally line
up for this to make sense i mean like
almost perfectly like uh their age gap
is like around five years like currently
within series shigaraki's 21 izuku is
16. yes so
when
izuku was born which is
the time his quirk would be taken in
this scenario it could have been given
to tenka when he turned five and it just
perfectly lined up yeah so the only way
it really works uh is if it was taken
when izuku was still just like a kid
like we're just infant right um so he's
let's say he's born he manifests the
cave very early on like maybe even while
he's still at the hospital kind of like
the luminescent baby and then you know
ujico happens to be at that hospital he
sees that he likes the cork decay he
steals it from deku without anyone
knowing and then years later he tries to
cover up by saying oh you were born
quirkless bro i mean that's precisely it
but you said
yuchiko happened to be there
that could be the case too
but i think it's more so that this was
like a strategic move on their end like
i think the whole um hospital ward or
whatever is like purposely set up for
all for one to possibly you know elope
with these women
to specifically try to breed quirks that
he wants or needs but that raises the
question of like i don't think they knew
that they were going to get dk because
yuji ko says that it's a rare variant
implying that like there's never been
decay before and that whoever was the
first person to have it you know was the
first person period
there is another possibility of deco
potentially having a quirk that was not
quite decay and then
all for one combining it with something
else to create the decay we know today
but either way yeah like the idea of
ujjiko and all for one stalking
maternity wards and looking for children
who materialize
strong quirks it makes sense because we
know already canonically that ujico was
doing that with kids that were albeit a
few years older but you know it wasn't
an accident or a coincidence that he
decided to become a doctor dealing with
children he was specifically interested
in looking at
next generation quirks because he
believes that quirks get stronger every
new generation right and he wanted to
find strong ones to have all for one
take exactly and that brings me to
another question which i'm curious to
hear your take on
uh we know that all for one at some
point had been duplicated um actually
a few times
i i think at least twice one was given
to nine and one was given to um i guess
all for one and then the main one is
with shigaraki so how exactly is all for
one being duplicated and another
question that goes into that is would
all for one
be passed down hereditarily
yeah all for one is such a and one for
all they're both such
well i guess one for all is artificially
created but all for one itself i guess
isn't it supposed to be a naturally
occurring quirk which is in itself
insane like what could
his parents quirks have been to create
something like that it's crazy
but i think um
uh just to real quick to go over that i
think all for one was in the first
generation of people to receive quirks
like his parents didn't even have them
oh maybe yeah yeah so because he was
he's generations old right that's a good
point yeah so he's like he has like the
apex predator of quirks the way i
understand the whole cloning quirks
process
is if you could just clone quirks you
wouldn't even need to steal quirks so
even if you know say let's say deck who
had decay
if would you go had already by then
figured out the cloning works process he
wouldn't even need to steal it and no
one would be the wiser i think that
probably the core cloning process is
newer
and it happened uh gradually because
nine has like an imperfect version of
all for one right yes so i'm thinking
that nine got an imperfect version while
they were still experimenting meaning
that the experiments are fairly recent
and then now right now where we are in
the story they perfected the procedure
but i'm guessing that when back when
shigeraki was five years old they hadn't
had that yet so they would have need to
needed to steal a quirk in order to give
it to shigaraki exactly and i mean that
just goes into if izuku was born with a
quirk was it an all-for-one duplicate
that was maybe passed down hereditarily
or was it decay you know
yeah
it's really interesting it might totally
turn out that deku wasn't born with a
quirk but it's really fascinating to
think about that type of stuff and as i
mentioned earlier in the video it would
be so poetic right to have the main
villain using the quirk that used to
belong to the hero to kill hundreds of
people like imagine
you know that revelation being dropped
on deku during the final fight it's like
what belonged to you is actually
responsible for all this evil and yeah
that would be pretty crazy i think
i'm thinking that's likely because
yujiko was set up hiding in plain sight
in the first episode it is weird to deku
you know both his parents have quirks
quirks are hereditary and yet he's born
quirkless it's not like one of his
parents or both his parents didn't have
quirks it seems to be an anomaly you
know maybe not in that world but it does
if you look at quirk singularity more
people are supposed to be getting quirks
and stronger quirks not less yeah
exactly but you bring up the parents
that that's the other big part of this
that we didn't even discuss yet all for
one uh potentially being izuku's father
oh yeah so i did a video of years ago on
that possibility and you know horikoshi
loves his
star wars references and you know having
all for one being like the darth vader
for deku that i could definitely see
that happening but it just i just think
inko is such like a nice person that she
would never
let herself get into something like that
unless all for one assumed like a total
second life and pretended to be his dad
but it's like that's a bit of a big
commitment for all for one you know he's
he's got a empire to run i don't know if
he would be willing to just uh pose as
deku's dad for like years well i mean i
don't even know if he did pose as his
dad for years it seems like
or at least it's implied that deku might
not even like know what his dad looks
like yeah but then you're saying inco
might be in on it right no no not at all
she she was deceived by him uh if it is
true but that's just why i asked if you
think all for one the quirk could be
passed down hereditarily uh which goes
into him being his father and him
purposely seeking out inco so that he
could have izuku to make the uh replica
of all for one yeah another weird thing
about inco
that i've never been able to figure out
why horakoshi has decided to put it into
the story but he keeps putting it out
there that she resembles nana oh yes for
sure for sure yeah all for one brings it
i'm not all for i'm saying all mike
brings it up uh and it's it's brought up
another time in the series and why is
that is it because
is she related to nana somehow and if
she is then that means that izuku is
related to shigeraki
yeah that's true and i i think
definitely all for one had an obsession
with kind of nana's family and that is
why he discovered shigeru in the first
place or tenko i believe he you know was
looking for them specifically one part
of it was probably revenge but the other
part he wanted to kind of keep an eye on
the son of nana to see whether all might
or grant torino were checking in on him
and you know find them that way and i
think that he realized
that tenko could be his
ideal vessel specifically because he
realized that they had this he had this
issues with his father the dynamic and
that he could you know he was clearly
quirkless five years in and that gave
him an opportunity to
do what he did exactly so you know if he
was exactly tracking down the family
it came down to izuku
was not the prime candidate but instead
it was shigaraki but izuku played a part
in the overall you know master plan yeah
i mean if it does turn out to be true
yeah that would be crazy honestly even
just the shigaraki part like the tenko
shimura part would be crazy on its own
right if it turns out that he was
actually quirkless and then he was given
decay
and even though it ended up killing his
family accidentally
because he didn't know how to use it
that totally served all for one's plan
anyway and he kind of orchestrated
tanko's entire life it makes sense on on
that side but also makes sense in terms
of quirkless people being better at
handling multiple quirks which we
learned right i also mentioned that
earlier in the video we learned that
deku and all might are better at
handling one for all because they were
born quirkless the same
could could work on all for one but also
on one for all eventually because of
course all for one wants to capture one
for all in the future and he wants to
use shigaraki to do it yes exactly uh
and that that just adds to it even more
uh because not just to the whole point
of him needing to be a vessel because of
the hatred and all of that in order for
him to forcibly to uh take over one for
all but the fact that he was also born
quirkless which i mean i i'm one i'm
like 100 positive that this is going to
be a thing for sure i'm just really
surprised that it hasn't even been
revealed yet it is it feels like the
whole dobby uh toya thing at this point
but
uh yeah him being quirkless just adds to
him being the perfect vessel uh for all
for one's perfect uh master plan yeah
man it makes a lot of sense and it's
something i didn't really think about
that much before until i saw your video
and then i was like yo this is all
making a ton of sense so yeah i can't
wait to find out whether
we're gonna get a flashback maybe in the
very next chapter and have that
confirmed that would be crazy zolan
thank you so much for joining me and
definitely everyone check out zonan i
will link him in the description
in the pinned comment as well he makes a
ton of videos every week on a bunch of
different series covers them all and
yeah he has some great ideas as i think
we just showcased in this video yeah
thank you anytime if you guys enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
videos like this in the future maybe
more collab videos like this one
definitely leave a like leave a comment
down below and of course don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting the bell and then
selecting that option that says all if
you don't do that you're still going to
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
thanks once again to zonin and of course
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible special thank you to alpha
sigma this guy is an absolute mad lad
and a disciple of lord twego himself and
i can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones that rise above all
other clans including ingrata algital
pate heffa hinukamian water the toasted
chi corey mcgowan the spike eight two
two seven kaido might be a gyarados
dylan isidore spidey life tinel tungsten
tarquez big buddhist cody hebert and
jeremy cummings finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the
red-haired ravens steelers on hell crews
very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks joy
and garcia fat boy games and jessica
rabbit if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value to you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these legendary people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you